all right this is a pepper panic saga
level 220 walk-through video
i'm gonna complete the level and i'm
gonna explain why i do what i do
uh this level starts with 55 moves and
it it takes a long time so i'm gonna
try to play as fast as i can
and i made one of these earlier and it
was like 20 minutes so i don't want to
be that long
for that reason make sure you read our
full guide for pepper panic saga level
221st
because that'll give you all the tips of
what i'm trying to do here
all right so this is a crates level if
you're not sure how crates work make
sure you read our crates guide that we
wrote um it'll explain all the uh
different things about them and how to
get rid of them and whatnot
one of the things that you want to do
when you play this level is
work your way down and and take out
these statues as you go
so we're gonna um
going to work our way down to the final
statute but we're going to try to take
these out as we go along
now you see when you first start there's
only three colors of peppers in play
and as we open up
crates that brings more colors in so now
there's four there'll be orange peppers
as well
so basically what i'm trying to do is
clear out these cake crates and then
also timers start to fall right away so
we want to try to control the numbers on
the timers as well
so you know exploding timers is fine we
don't want to move
remove too many of the crates in the
middle if we can help it because that's
going to bring another color out as well
it's going to bring out green
as you can see right there
as long as we don't remove a lot of
green we won't have more green dropping
into the into the
into the board
okay so we're getting kind of a slow
start here we haven't been able to make
a lot of matches on the side
due to the small space in the beginning
but we're that's still what we're trying
to do is just get
get rid of these uh crates so that we
can
explode some peppers on that side
now we got a big orange one sitting
there so we're gonna go ahead and
explode that
of course it won't remove that crate but
it did give us a hit on that statue
let's see so we have a blue one sitting
in both of our spots but no blue ones
around so
just kind of
get rid of some of the timers and see
how things fall into place
you know by doing that we got some more
blues on the board still not as many as
we need though
and i don't know if you were paying
attention but that was a uh that timer
on that yellow was a one so i had to
explode that to get rid of it
look at the fact that there's these
greens but they're all just sort of
sitting where they were first um
where they first were freed
watch if we pick up some of those as we
go how how new ones will take their
place right away
i don't think i can get rid of this one
um
but the yellows will be right up next to
it so
i figured growing that yellow one will
make it so we can get rid of that one
right away so that's not it's not the
end of the world when the timers turn
you just don't want to get too many of
them in the way
now we have well we we had oranges
sitting next to it
i'm gonna go ahead and match that and
get rid of it because of the timers
but as you can see we haven't really
messed with the green or match them so
they haven't no no new green ones have
fallen into the top yet
now that blue one's in a good spot so
i'm gonna go ahead and start a chain
reaction with those
same with the yellow this will hit this
statue on the side so we'll get rid of
that one
the orange are down to
number one here but i don't think we can
do much about that at the moment
all right so now you see that the green
got matched and look now these green
ones are going to come in at the top
so you want to try to control that as
much as you can because
as you can see right now it's pretty
easy to get explosions and big matches
and things when we get down to the
bottom there's going to be more
of those colors and it's going to get a
lot harder
there's really not a great move here i
guess since this orange one sitting here
i'll do that
you can see how just this just those few
greens that are mixed in how much
they get in the way
i haven't been able to i think that it's
a fixed number
as far as we can see here that the
number stays the same i never taken the
time to like count them all or whatever
but um
you know it's like like you see there's
one purple sitting here if we shot this
purple new purple will fall so you know
we kind of want to avoid doing that if
we can
because you could think about some of
the tougher levels in the game that have
a lot of different colors on board like
um
level 155 stan you know comes to mind
when i think of that like
it's just a lot harder to
actually do anything because you know
you have peppers in the way from making
your matches level 158 another one that
has
that's a real pain because of the number
of colors
all right so
once we get here we want to start
thinking about destroying these statues
so we want to look for shockwave matches
like this one to
send waves down
we knocked out a purple so we'll see
another one fall here
shortly
there it is
but we did a pretty good job of leaving
all these crates that we you know that
weren't essential to actually
destroying the statues
we kept the number down pretty good on
this try
doesn't mean that we're going to finish
on this try but it it gives us a better
shot at it for sure
go ahead and get rid of that mummy or
petrified pepper
i'm going to try to explode a red so we
can get
the damage there
if we blow up this one it's going to
open up another crate so i'm looking for
another
opportunity but i don't really see one
so we're just gonna have to do that
and we don't really
i mean
we're not avoiding pepper panics by any
you know
by any means but we don't really need
the start one right here um it would
grow it would get rid of this like
larger timer pepper
but really what we want to do more is
send shock waves down
and look for
matches
that'll
explode that color so here's one where
we can set up a down shock wave
i don't know we could have but it
disappeared
this will take out that statue so that's
good
we don't mind at all if these peppers on
the side turn to stone
that's fine
because they're out of the way
and the ones in the middle are a little
bit more of a problem so we'll try to
get rid of those while we can
here's another shock wave going down
another one going down
and it's funny because we have one
statue
and i still don't feel confident that
we're going to finish this year i mean
we have a pretty good shot
but
you know it's
it's kind of crazy how
close you can get sometimes on this
board
okay so we'll scan for shock waves going
down in this row we don't have any we
have a red one sitting down here
so i'm gonna go ahead and
grow the red
look again for a chance for a shockwave
um it looks like
so you can set one up here if it stays
oh no that's not gonna work
but here we go
all right so
that's how you complete the level like i
said i played a lot faster that time
because i didn't want to make this be a
uh a really long a really long
video because the last one was twice as
long
but
hopefully you saw how i used
the
the tips from the guide i mean
keeping as many of this keeping as many
of the the other colors
numbers down the purple and green don't
open up all those crates if you don't
have to
take out those statues on the sides as
you go
and just always take your time to try to
find the best match i mean you have a
lot of different things you have to
think about you have to think about
controlling the number of timers you
have to think about
um
you know
are you going to be able to set up shots
to to hit the statues and then you also
like i said want to keep
track of how many crates you're actually
opening so you don't get a lot of other
colors onto the board
so i hope that helps i hope you'll be
able to finish the level it it takes a
lot of tries sometimes
and it can really wear you out so take a
break if you need to
if you have any questions leave a
comment and we'll get back to you right
away make sure you subscribe to our
youtube channel like us on facebook and
share this
guide if it helped you out so that other
people can read it too thanks